a determined student gets some major
money for her college career brian
loftus explains
[Music]
a standout student earning a 100 000
college scholarship in what's cool at
school and i plan to major in computer
science
eight news now recently featured 20
local high school seniors who were
surprised with college scholarship
awards
from the rogers foundation
congratulations to all of today's
recipients
these rogers achiever scholarships range
from twenty to one hundred thousand
dollars the big winner
of the hundred thousand dollar
scholarship was an advanced technologies
academy senior
simone moore that leaves simone moore as
our one hundred thousand dollar
scholarship winner we wanted to follow
up with simone and speak with her about
this
unbelievable life-changing experience i
was so excited
to have received that in that moment
like
it was it was like a dream come true
receiving this scholarship has taken a
huge burden away from me and away from
my family
um now i can focus on school and that
focus
involves lofty goals usc or loyola
marymount in the fall
majoring in global health or biology i
want to become a doctor
and i want to become a doctor in africa
my name is simone moore
i go to advanced technology simone is
passionate about providing quality
health care to the areas and people that
need it most the pandemic
even help to clarify that vision of her
future path
covet at least for me really helped me
see just how essential
you know health care workers are and how
necessary
health care is in quality health care
rogers achievers scholarship was
developed to give the brightest clark
county students the assistance
needed to achieve their educational
goals with their focus on education the
rogers foundation
ultimately awarded more than 2 million
dollars in scholarships
to see the rogers foundation to see how
much they support education
and from all s aspects they support
teachers
they support students they even give
grants to schools
it changes lives and it's amazing it
definitely changed yours didn't it
it did it really did and that's what's
cool at school
if you know something that's cool at
school just head to 8newsnow.com
click on cool at school under the
community tab or send us an email cool
at school at eight newsnow dot com